I've never ate so much kimchi in my life
in one day
beautiful guilty because it's healthy
today we are here to try customizable
kimchi from kind people you I do love
kimchi I've tried it before with Korean
barbecue team cheese is a traditional
Korean pickled cabbage to say it easy it
has a lot of health benefits probiotic -
orange pineapple lobster gold mango
oyster Kiwi apple caviar
most importantly I like this good look
at that
whose exclusive let's see
wait we need to put our pinkie up this
is Mooji I feel like I'm taking a bite
out of like I don't know like the most
clearest water or something it's very
refreshing yeah that's more vinegary
than I thought yeah I really like it
gentleman how spicy is that it's a
little spicy
ha ha so much actually the first time he
strike some spice
Wow spicy really you called that like
little spicy yeah a little spicy what's
the difference from the red and then
it's season it's the same way but then
this one has red pepper in it oh how
about this gold gold gold okay that one
board yeah okay sweet that is sweet Wow
yeah it doesn't necessary have to be
spicy oldest I know it's a wolf
it tastes like seafood to me am I just
weird maybe mango Wow Wow mango sticks
no the man was made and really good I
really like a pineapple one my favorite
is pineapple deafness is focused my hair
it's apple or I know so for this you
dude chew it yeah see that I've only had
in the length Oh oysters yeah like you
don't like this isn't right
I don't I'm good are you scared
[Music]
what do you think I'm sorry these some
of the clothes done I feel like I just
looked at you see creature I gotta say
look wise it's the gold but overall the
mango is amazing it was really really
good you prefer it on the sweet right
yeah definitely I would say the Kiwi I
like I like the Kiwi and kimchi is great
for me
you can put cold anywhere I'm gonna love
it okay I'll just love it I know
actually I never had a goal inside of my
life even the spicy one
I like caviar and pineapple so I think
I'll maybe try to mix them up I feel
like it changes not now make uppity
everything else for sure it's a delicacy
that could be placed on really anything
I feel
[Music]